- Sometimes, an indirect route
is the quickest way to get there.
Do something that you know you can do
and go for it at 150 million percent.
I just wanted to be the best, be hot,
and just have something hot,
hear my voice on the radio.
You don't have to stop.
It's just a matter of
you caring enough to always pay attention.
I just make my records
and let the chips fall.
You can do anything you put your mind to,
you know what I'm saying?
There's no limitations to this.
Dad, you're fired.
You, my assistant, you're fired too.
You, you're fired.
Everybody's fired.
Be like a tiger.
Just attack your dreams
with aggression and power.
If I'm not here to maximize my potential,
then what am I on earth for?
You're not successful 'til
you've went 360 degrees
full cipher, the full cycle, then die.
Then you're successful.
He's an American hip hop recording artist
and actor from Queens, New York.
He's known as one of the
forefathers of pop rap.
He's released 13 studio albums
and two greatest hits compilations.
He's LL Cool J, and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
You know, where I come from,
people are very passionate.
Hot blooded.
They want it.
They want it now!
I need it right away! Everyone's
looking for a shortcut,
but sometimes an indirect route
is the quickest way to get there.
Sometimes you've got
to take a little longer
to achieve the things
you will achieve in life.
So don't be in a hurry.
Be patient.
Everybody wants everything now.
We live in a society where
there's instant gratification.
Instagram, insta-this.
Be patient.
- [Interviewer] A lot of
kids, when they're growing up,
there's a lot of stuff they
think that they can't do.
They're told they can't be
this, they can't be that.
- What you have to do is, if you're
in a situation like that, you
have to gain focus in yourself
and go forward yourself.
Don't listen.
- So how do you--
- Just focus.
- [Interviewer] How would
you tell somebody to do that
if they don't have that power,
they think they're not capable of it?
- You got to get confidence
and find something
that you do feel confident about.
Find something that you feel
confident you can achieve.
Do something that you know you can do
and go for it at 150 million percent.
- [Interviewer] So how
did you know it was music?
- That's what I like.
I know.
It's what I love.
- [Interviewer] For real,
from the first time?
- Absolutely.
- Way back when?
For me, it doesn't matter what I do.
I could do all of the Hollywood stuff
and I do all that, and
everybody knows about that part
of my life.
Yeah, all of that.
But you know what?
There is nothing on earth
more fun and crazy and wild
for me than just getting
on the records and rhyming
and hear my joint on the
radio, hear my joint at a club.
Yo, look, I could host a zillion Grammys.
I could do TV shows or shoot
bazookas and blow cars up
and do all of that, but
none of that gives me
the adrenaline rush and the
thrill that music gives me.
You know what I'm saying?
And so when you put your heart
and soul and your passion
into something, I can't walk
away from that just because
it never was business for me.
It was always personal.
You know what I'm saying?
Music was always personal
to me and I know that's almost
weird and that everywhere
it's all about being a
businessman, but for me,
music was always personal.
I just wanted to be the best,
be hot, and just have something hot,
hear my voice on the radio,
be heard, and just feel it.
That's what my whole career
is based on, you know.
Longevity, versatility, originality,
you know what I'm saying?
Giving them the longevity,
but being versatile enough
to adapt as time moves on.
And then being original
enough, not being a follower,
not being a guy that, you
know, you're leading the pack
and then when things
switch up, all the sudden
you start following.
But actually keeping it fresh,
still believing in your taste.
You know what I'm saying?
I got a lot of little young
homies that stay around me
and a lot of little cats
that I hang out with
and stuff like that, but
just believing in yourself
and doing what you love.
That's the thing I love
about this culture.
You don't have to stop.
It's just a matter of you caring enough
to always pay attention.
- To what's going on?
- Absolutely.
Well, see, with me, I don't
concentrate on black or pop.
I make an LL record, I make
the best record I can make,
I put it out there and
present it to the people.
You know?
I mean, it's like a painting.
I mean, if 500 people get
online to see my painting today
the next painting is 5,000,
and the next painting is 3,000,
and the next painting is 40,000
and the next painting is 2,000
that's just the way it is.
You know, I'm interested in radio play,
but at the same time, I
just make what I make,
and I don't know how to cross over.
I don't know how to go pop.
I just make my records
and let the chips fall.
I got a line on the album, I
don't remember the exact line,
but I was just basically saying that
when my first album dropped,
Jordan was a rookie.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- You know what I'm saying,
just to put it in perspective,
my first album cover, I had
the first ever pair of Jordans
from the first release.
The first--
- [Radio Host] Is that
standing on the car?
- Yeah, no, no, that's my second album.
This is my first one,
and you know, it's crazy,
because it just shows you
that you can do anything
you put your mind to,
you know what I'm saying,
there's no limitations to this.
There was a point when I started hearing,
"You know, you're having tax problems."
But my father was running
my whole financial life.
He was dealing with the checks,
he was dealing with everything.
I hardly was doing anything,
and around that time,
I was starting to get back
with the mother of my children.
And I remember looking at
my son and saying to myself,
you know, how can I look
at this young man here
and tell him I'm his father
if I'm not even taking care of myself?
I have all these people around
me telling me what to do
and what not to do.
Who I should be with, and
who I shouldn't be with.
And I have a son here
who's going to depend on me
to take care of him and
look out for him, raise him.
Dad, you're fired.
You, my assistant, you're fired too.
You, you're fired.
Everybody's fired.
Yeah, hello?
Yeah, I'm trying to figure out
where the GD program is.
Oh, I know where it is.
My uncle tells me, I go out there.
I join in.
You understand what I'm saying?
It's like there's a period, you know,
you got to take control,
you got to take the reins.
Yes, I have people in
my life that help me,
because you know, wise men
attains wise counsel, obviously.
And you want to have that
mastermind principle going on.
You want to have a lot
of people around you,
have a think tank flowing.
But at the same time,
you got to be able to take
care of your own life,
and that was what was important to me.
I decided, you know
what, I want to be able
to take care of my own life.
I have to be able
to be in charge, on some
level, of my own life.
I guess what it all boils
down to at the end of the day
is how bad you want it,
how hard are you willing
to work for it and what are you willing
to sacrifice to get it?
You don't have to
sacrifice your integrity.
You don't have to sacrifice
who you are as a human being,
the principles, the values
that are instilled in you
by your mentors or your family.
You may have to sacrifice some sleep.
The successful people in this
room lost a lot of sleep.
Oh, yeah.
They're tired now; look at them.
Bags under their eyes; "Oh,
God, when's he going to finish?
"Jesus.
"Oh, my God.
"I love the kids, but God."
Which, you know,
that's really what it's about.
Just believing in yourself.
So I say that to say this:
Keep going after your dreams,
keep going after your goals,
pursue them relentlessly.
Dig deep down into your soul.
Hold onto that dream that's inside of you.
Don't let go no matter what.
Be like a pit bull.
Be like a tiger.
Just attack your dreams with aggression
and power, but be polite
while you're doing it.
Have faith in yourself.
Have faith in your god.
Listen to your mentors, and love you.
You know, my mother used to
tell me, "Todd, you can do
"anything you put your mind to."
And my grandmother used
to tell me, "If a task
"is once begun, never
leave it til it's done.
"be thy labor great or small,
do it well or not at all."
And I kind of grew up with that mantra.
I grew up believing that you can do
anything you put your mind to.
And I don't,
no matter what, I am extremely determined.
I am abnormally--
- That need to succeed
never goes away, right?
- It's not just a general
succeed for the sake of succeeding.
It's a desire to create,
you know what I'm saying?
To use the godly power and
talent that was instilled in me
to the best of my ability,
to maximize my potential.
Because if I'm not here
to maximize my potential,
then what am I on earth for?
- [Interviewer] How do you
set goals for yourself?
- Decide what you want to do and do it.
- [Interviewer] Do they
change all the time?
- The quicker you set your goals,
the quicker you'll achieve them.
As you achieve them, they change.
- [Interviewer] So what would
make you, when you go to bed
at night, what makes you
think yeah, I'm successful?
- I don't.
- You don't?
- I don't feel like I'm successful.
Success, to me,
is living a complete life,
being rich physically,
mentally, and spiritually,
and dying rich physically,
and then ascending to a higher place.
That's success.
Because you could say you're successful
and then next day lose what you
thought made you successful.
So you're not successful
til you went 360 degrees
full cipher, the full cycle, and die.
Then you're successful
because you completed life.
You were successful with the whole thing.
- [Interviewer] Where'd you get that?
- Me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah?
Is that something that came
from your mom or your parents or?
- Mm-mm.
- Really?
Because it does ascribe to
some certain religious ideas.
- For me, this is something I feel inside.
My life force tells me that.
- Thank you so much for watching.
- We made this video
because Rodney asked us to.
If you have another entrepreneur
you want us to profile,
leave it in the comments below.
- I'd also love to know which
of LL Cool J's top 10 rules
hit you the hardest.
Leave it in the comments below
and join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe
and we'll see you soon.